à quoi ressemble vraiment une semaine à
l'assemblée nationale comme en devient
député combien gagne un député ou un
traitement comment travaille un député
si on a une vie privée quand on est élu
et comment est ce qu'on vit les
critiques celles j'espère que vous allez
bien après françois hollande qui nous a
révélé les secrets du quotidien d'un
président de la république après sergei
gernot fait une haie maurane qui nous
ont dévoilé les secrets de la vie d'un
espion qui après thomas pesquet
notamment qui nous a révélé les secrets
de la vie dans l'espace l'aurez compris
on revient pour un quatrième épisode
avec les députés clémentine autain et
sasha ollier qui vont nous dévoiler tous
les secrets de la vie des députés sacha
oubliez donc députés dans la vienne il
est membre de la république en marche
des mails macron tandis que clémentine
autain et député en seine saint denis et
membre de la france insoumise de jean
luc mélenchon tous les deux ont été élu
député pour la première fois en 2017 ils
sont à nouveau candidat cette année et
donc vous allez voir ce qu intéressant
la façon dont ils perçoivent leur rôle à
noter qu'on a choisi ces deux députés
parce que ça nous permet d'avoir à la
fois un député qui était du même camp
que est bien le président un public donc
sacha oublié qu'ils étaient du côté de
la république en marche sur les cinq
dernières années et ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir une députée de l'opposition en
l'occurrence on a donc choisi ces deux
parties car ces deux camps ont des
chances d'arriver en tête à l'assemblée
nationale à l'occasion de ces élections
à l'initiative de 2022 et donc ils
peuvent être représentatifs d'une partie
du moins de l'assemblée nationale pour
les cinq années à venir évidemment que
cette vidéo j'ai pas pu interviewer les
577 députés et donc c'est un bon aperçu
alors n'hésitez pas à vous abonner jeu
mais ce n'est pas encore le cas pour ne
pas louper les épisodes suivants de
cette série qui a l'air de beaucoup
plaire n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à
proposer des métiers ou des
personnalités dans les commentaires vous
aussi vous abonner à notre compte
instagram pour ne pas louper le débrief
des résultats dimanche soir les deux
dimanches des élections les 12 et 19
juin j'arrête de parler et je vous
laisse donc tout de suite avec la vidéo
comment et pourquoi on devient député
vous êtes député parce que vous avez des
convictions parce que vous remplissez
les conditions légales 18 ans la
nationalité française mais parce que
vous avez des convictions et nous avons
une base pour ça et moi c'est un peu ce
qui m'arrive et moi j'étais j'étais
militant politique depuis depuis mes 17
ans j'ai milité des années durant pour
d'autres personnes qui avaient les mêmes
convictions que moi après je suis devenu
avocat et je me suis dit bon bah si tu
as mené moi j'ai une carrière
professionnelle etc et puis j'ai remis
le doigt dedans j'ai créé des jeunes
avec macro et député qui était la
députée de poitiers madiba si tu y vas
je te soutiens et je me suis présenté
aux élections et j'ai gagné dans les
classes dans lesquelles je vais moi je
dis souvent aux élèves il n'y a pas
besoin de diplôme pourquoi êtes-vous du
député
je fais partie des porte-voix pour la
seine-saint-denis chevet du de seine
saint denis et être porte-voix des
inégalités que nous subissons j'aime
estime est particulièrement utile pour
les habitants je représente mais quand
on est dans l'opposition forcément à
part voilà on est surtout déportement
alors à quoi ressemble une semaine à
l'assemblée nationale
alors ça dépend des semaines ça c'est
clair parce que ça dépend de l'actualité
de la circonscription et de l'actualité
de l'assemblée nationale en fait le
temps du député est un petit peu divisé
en deux avec d'un côté tout le temps qui
va passer à l'assemblée nationale donc à
paris et de l'autre côté et bien tout le
temps qui va passer dans sa
circonscription c'est à dire donc le
lieu où le député a été élu car oui je
le rappelle un les députés sont élus
localement par exemple clémentine autain
et élus dans la 11e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis et sasha oublier est
élu dans la deuxième circonscription de
la vienne ça veut dire que le lundi
généralement je suis en circonscription
je reçois des gens j'ai des
inaugurations je vais sur le terrain
juste les entreprises je vais dans des
écoles faire des cours d'éducation
civique le lundi soir ou mardi matin
j'arrive à l'assemblée hélas tout
s'enchaîne assez méthodiquement c'est à
dire une réunion de groupe le matin avec
vos parlementaires des déjeuners de
travail les questions gouvernement de 15
à 17 heures en gros lors des séances de
questions au gouvernement qui selon lui
a diffusé à la télévision et bien 15
députés peuvent poser une question à un
membre du gouvernement et ces questions
sont divisés entre la majorité et
l'opposition
qui est clair c'est que le mardi et le
mercredi on est à l'assemblée puisqu'il
ya les questions d'actualité et les
réunions de commission puisque chaque
député siège dans une des commissions
j'étais aux affaires étrangères et donc
c'est le mercredi matin général en effet
chaque député appartient une commission
c'est en fait un groupe de travail au
sein de l'assemblée nationale à chaque
fois chaque commission et sur un thème
différent et dans les commissions et
bien les députés de plusieurs partis
différents travaillent ensemble pour
préparer les textes de loi là c'est
obligatoire tout pour tout le monde
travail en commission près de 9 heures à
13 heures au minimum avec obligation de
signature sinon on a des retenues sur
notre immunité et après ça se déroule
progressivement l'assemblée où je reste
jusqu'au jeudi après-midi ou vendredi
matin le plus tard il retourne
circonscription de vendredi c'est pareil
je reçois des gens à mon bureau quand on
a la chance comme moi de pouvoir aller
et venir même si je suis en grande
banlieue je reste quand même sur le
territoire francilien là ça permet de
partager la semaine d'avoir des fins de
semaine plus dédiée à la présence locale
quand vous êtes parlementaire vous
pouvez décider de faire une semaine de
35 heures ou une semaine de cinq heures
c'est vous qui décidez pourquoi est-ce
que l'hémicycle et donc l'assemblée
nationale paraît parfois aussi vide si
un député et h24 dans l'hémicycle ça
veut dire que c'est un député qui n'est
pas au contact de la population qu'ils
représentent certains députés qui ne
travaillent pas contenté dans
l'hémicycle espace mille choses à côté
des auditions en commission pouvoir des
missions d'information même temps vous
avez bout de gras défendent pour votre
circonscription auprès d'un ministre
auquel vous pouvez avoir pris rendez
vous donc en fait tout le travail
cumulées et le fait que vous pouvez pas
être partout on peut être présent à
jeanne 4 dans l'hémicycle et être un
parlementaire absolument inutile
absolument inutile parce que il ya du
travail invisible que l'on fait quand
par exemple on reçoit dans notre
permanence
des personnes qui ont besoin d'un
soutien d'une aide pour une demande de
régularisation de papier pour des enjeux
de logements alors la permanence est en
fait le bureau du député dans sa
circonscription
elle est donc ouverte à tous les
citoyens qui peuvent prendre rendez vous
avec leur député pour le rencontrer et
pour échanger sur des problèmes qu'ils
connaissent il ya aussi tout le travail
qu'il travail d'élaboration quel travail
de vie publique aussi parce que je pense
que quand on est parlementaire on
participe du débat politique et donc
participer du débat politique ça veut
dire prendre du temps pour venir
voir à prendre du temps pour écrire
éventuellement prendre du temps pour
réfléchir si on n'a pas ce temps de
lecture de rencontre de spécialistes sur
des sujets d'associations etc je pense
qu'on n'est pas mais parlementaire voilà
a nourri et qui pouvons avoir des
positions éclairé et puis il ya des
moments où on peut être à fond à
l'assemblée moi je l'étais sur la
question des retraites donc la cdu et à
un moment donné c'était nuit joue en
huit jours pendant plusieurs semaines en
vérité donc là ça devient très concentré
et puis d'autres moments où il ya moins
d'activités on a des fois on siège du
lundi matin
au dimanche soir non-stop c'est à dire
une séance le matin une séance l'après
midi une séance le soir qui peuvent
durer parfois jusqu'à quatre heures du
matin ça peut aller jusqu'à 80 heures
dans la semaine
soit ça c'est pour les excès 1 soit on
passe une loi allait en 20 heures sur
une lecture le but c'est pas de bons
puis il restait trop parce que ce qu'on
ne travaille dans l'hémicycle il est
bonifié par tout ce qu'on sait à côté on
a souvent l'impression que c'est
beaucoup le bazar dans l'hémicycle
pourquoi est-ce que parfois il ya un tel
bazar nous aussi on se lève et on se
marre et à la séance spectacle c'est
celle de mardi après-midi à l'abri les
mardis et mercredis maintenant c'est
commencer juste de mardi est question
gouvernement bat déjà il ya tout
gouvernement donc c'est là où on pose
des questions les plus brûlantes donc
que ce soit animée c'est un peu logique
ça reste l'assemblée nationale ça reste
ça peut être l'image qu'on en avait déjà
au moment de la révolution ou non de la
troisième république qui est encore ce
moment là où il ya un peu de vert
d'interpellations on bouscule le
gouvernement je pense que c'est sans la
d'abord heureusement qu'on est un peu
animé deux passions aussi pour les idées
qu'on défendre alors parfois ça devient
des joutes un peu viril un peu de pure
forme je trouve presque comme au théâtre
comme un exercice de style et puis on en
voit deux ils se sont écharpés
finalement la buvette il trinque et puis
voilà donc on se dit c'est un peu vain
il ya d'autres moments où je pense que
c'est quand même très important aussi
d'exprimer cette colère de tenir bon est
ce que ja il devenu obligatoire à
l'assemblée nationale à la cravate alors
la gelée pas ça c'est un débat qu'on
s'est posée le début des députés un
swing de pâte kraft etc alors je suis
papa bien visé parce qu'il emporte pas
la même mais moi j'ai toujours été pour
nous il est toujours nu à cravate dans
l'hémicycle on les a fait bouger ces
règles puisque on a on avait pris cette
décision de groupe avec une discussion
qui était assez amusante entre nous ce
qu'il y avait des hommes particulier qui
voulait pas mettre la cravate or la
cravate était censé être obligatoire et
donc on a dit bahain premier jour aucun
homme chez nous mettra la cravate donc
on désobéit d'une certaine manière à la
règle et c'est une question de respect
qu'on doit je pense aux électeurs qu'on
représente voire même aux collègues avec
lesquels on discute bon c'est peut-être
un peu vieux jeu mais je pense que cette
tenue correcte exigée si on peut dire ça
c'est c'est un élément important c'est
une question d'égalité et une égalité
vers le haut cet uniforme dix députés ça
nous plaît pas du tout avant nous avant
le monde 2017 s'il y avait effectivement
costume-cravate obligatoire pour les
hommes est-ce que du coup on a du temps
pour soi pour sa vie personnelle etc
quand on est député c'est vrai qu'après
et à la vie de famille la vie
personnelle et c'est là où il faut être
très organisé mes collaborateurs le
savent il ya tant de soirée où
il se débrouille mais il faut que voilà
que je puisse être à la maison avec mes
enfants il ya en cours de route aussi le
besoin de faire du sport d'avoir une
activité physique parce que c'est
intense le travail qui a un côté h24 qui
s'arrête un peu jamais et puis la
tension nerveuse parce que c'est aussi
une activité où il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de l'agressivité de tension de stress
donc il faut aussi pouvoir l'évacuer
voilà moi g
mais mon équation personnelle avec le
tapis de yoga comme quand on est
passionné on a peu tout faut savoir que
moi je pense qu'ils pensent que la
politique c'est pas un métier et donc on
y est un peu plus que que son métier
c'est comme des gens qui créent leur
entreprise comme des gens qui dirigent
leur association c'est comme des gens
qui s'impliquent dans un club sportif
dont ils sont ils sont membres donc ça
c'est extrêmement chronophage on essaie
de gérer avec sa famille on essaie de
gérer que sa passion et ses loisirs
j'essaie de faire un petit peu de vélo
beaucoup de motos à côté question simple
mais beaucoup ont vu combien gagne un
député vous avez 5700 euros nets vous
êtes député cehl meeah parlementaire
c'est c'est toujours trop pour les
français qui nous regardent parce que
ils se disent bas attendait tout
l'argent qu'on leur donne si jamais
assez pour tout ceux qui estiment faire
un boulot et qui prend tout prendre
jusqu'à 90 ou 100 l'a finalement je
pense que c'est un juste milieu il faut
que des parlementaires soit soit bien
rémunérés pour les fonctions qu'ils
exercent pour lutter contre la
corruption aussi mais le montant s'est
toujours sujet à un débat qui est qui
sera jamais tranchée en fait certains
estiment que si les députés reçoivent
une indemnisation qui est suffisamment
élevée et bien ils seront alors moins
tentés par la corruption c'est à dire
par exemple un des cadeaux ou de
l'argent venant d'une entreprise ou d'un
lobby en échange du vote de telle ou
telle mesure qui servirait les intérêts
de cette entreprise vous avez 5300 euros
qui ont des frais de mandat c'est
absolument pas du revenu faut pas le
considérer comme tel et avec mais avec
cette enveloppe si on utilise
correctement on se rend compte que ça va
assez vite parce que c'est avec ça qu'on
peut communiquer dans sa circonscription
il ya plein de choses en fait le
matériel informatique
louer une permanence parlementaire
capable sur le même prix suivants là là
où on est élu c'est aussi dans cette
enveloppe là donc c'est une enveloppe
cas quand même normalement une fonction
précise et qui est maintenant beaucoup
plus contrôlés car les frais sont
contrôlés c'est très bien ainsi
d'ailleurs depuis 2017 j'étais au bureau
de l'assemblée nationale des
vice-présidentes on l'a fait je suis
très fier de cette réforme
combien de personnes y at il dans
l'équipe députés
en fait on a une enveloppe pour payer
mes collaborateurs moi j'étais une
personne qui travaille avec moi on s'est
vraiment investi avec beaucoup de gens y
en a trois qui sont à poitiers une qui
est à paris est une qui fait la
migration avec moi tout toutes les
semaines donc qui prend le train le
début de semaine et qui rentrent à la
comme beaucoup de députés je suis
entouré de trois collaborateurs il y en
a qui en ont plus si on a peu je pense
qu'il ya quel sont les méthodes
possibles des députés de l'opposition
souvient au début de la mandature celle
qui est en train de se terminer alexis
corbière qui était arrivé avec des
boîtes de conserve en fait il avait
montré ce que pouvait représenter les 5
euros d'apl que supprimer le
gouvernement et le fait qu'il est sorti
ce qui pouvait acheter avec 5 euros mais
nous on trouve que c'est aussi est une
manière d'intéresser à l'extérieur notre
pire angoisse c'était de se dire que ces
débats reste enfermé entre quatre murs
parce qu'en fait ce qu'il faut c'est que
les citoyennes et les citoyens sachent
les batailles qui sont donnés à l'inter
de cet hémicycle a pas toujours des
amendements qui sont qui sont d'accord
avec le gouvernement mais il faut
toujours plus nombreux que l'opposition
et si un travail est assez cesti dieu
parce que l'opposition a beaucoup
d'outils pour ralentir la procédure
et donc la façon dont on domine et ex
non elle a utilisé dans une méthode
assez classique et celle de
l'obstruction donc à déposer des
dizaines de milliers d'amendements
parfois absurdes au sens où on pousse le
curseur de l'absurdité pour dénoncer en
fait la loi qui est en cours donc ça on
a plutôt bien réussi sur les retraites
parce que comme ça ça faisait gagner du
temps qu'il y avait des mobilisations
dans la rue et qu'au bout d'un moment et
ben ça a permis que ça s'arrête et on a
gagné en fait au moment de la réforme
des retraites les députés de la france
mise ont déposé 23 mille amendements
pour ralentir au maximum l'examen du
texte c'est ce que l'on appelle une
technique d'obstruction parlementaire
cette photo montre un autre exemple on y
voit le président de l'assemblée
nationale en deux 6 jean louis debré qui
pose devant les 137
1665 amendement qui a été déposée par
l'opposition et ceux concernant une loi
qui prévoyait à l'époque la fusion de
gdf et suez est ce que les députés de la
république en marche sont toujours
d'accord avec le gouvernement le procès
qui est fait aux députés la pluie comme
archi il est un peu sévère parce que
c'est qu'on le plus suivi les consignes
du groupe c les défis de la france info
news qui ont voté le plus avec leur gros
comme on les a appelés nous les députés
de la majorité sera des playmobil et
c'est globalement ce qui s'est passé
donc c'est exténuant d'abord au bout de
un certain nombre d'années d'être dans
l'hémicyle de répéter répéter des choses
et de se rendre compte ba oui on est
vraiment pas entendu et mis sur le bas
côté mais sans doute même pour des
marcheurs qui ont souvent eu le
sentiment qu'on leur demandait d'appuyer
sur un bouton sans pouvoir eux mêmes
avoir un point de vue
entendu ou de pouvoir faire bouger des
textes véritablement fait d'accord sur
beaucoup de choses avec la majorité vous
avez fait campagne sur un programme
commun heureusement que vous êtes
d'accord sur deux se battent et à la
marche pas vous avez des différences et
quand vous avez des différences vous
devez les faire valoir et convaincre le
plus de vos collègues qui ont quand même
plus de chances d'être d'accord avec le
ministre des parcs avec vous le si
jamais senti impuissant parce que je me
suis toujours battu voilà c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile de se battre
quand on est dans la majorité parfois à
contre courant mais je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'on est utiles vous avez déjà
voté une loi contre vos convictions
j'ai pas de souvenir d'avoir voté contre
mes convictions après c'est facile aussi
dans un rôle d'opposition au sens où on
a beaucoup voté contre quand même et
donc j'ai toujours voté contre avec
beaucoup de conviction sur ce qu'a fait
la macro ni donc ça c'est pas ça s'est
pas trop posé et après il ya toujours
une hypothèse quand on n'est pas très à
l'aise sur un sujet c'est ce qu'on
appelle avoir piscine c'est à dire à ce
moment là ne pas être dans l'hémicycle
pour ne pas appuyer sur le bouton est-ce
que vous avez déjà désobéi à une
consigne de vote de votre parti pourra
contre sécurité globale où je me suis
monsieur abstenus
s'abstenir déjà contraint dans la
majorité sur un texte qui est proposée
par vos collègues c'est un acte de
défiance qui est assez fort la loi de
sécurité globale c'est donc une loi qui
avait créé beaucoup beaucoup de débats à
l'assemblée nationale en 2020 et 2021
cette loi a été porté par des députés en
marché elles donner plus de pouvoirs aux
policiers notamment et certains estiment
et bien que c'était une atteinte à de
nombreuses libertés alors sache à
oublier fait partie des députés de la
république en marche qui se sont
abstenus sur le vote de cette loi aux
bandits n'ont pas voté contre mais ils
n'ont pas voté pour non plus vous ne
voulez pas voter contre oui parce que je
suis pour la mutualisation des forces de
police municipale et nationale oui parce
que je suis pour plus de formations de
la sécurité privée qui est plein de
choses qui m'allait dans ce texte là
il ya christophe castaner qui est juste
derrière moi qui est un ami de longue
date et voilà et qui renseigne les
intérieurs qui a préparé une cantine
texte on voit appuyer sur le bouton
abstention et une petite asso des
paulines dit m que pensez-vous de la
méfiance et les critiques vis-à-vis des
hommes et des femmes politiques
aujourd'hui en france vous parlez un
député qui a eu cette annonce dégrader
neuf fois dont un incendie et des choses
qui sont un peu folklorique qui peut le
fumier devant la permanence aux
agriculteurs et des tags de gilet jaune
il ya eu donc un incendie avec des
vitres brisées c'est sûr que c'est ultra
violent ça les insultes les réseaux
sociaux c'est pas facile tout le temps
donc je vous avoue que c'est enfin c'est
parfois même c'est presque juste vexant
mais on se dit finalement ça veut dire
que les gens quand ils sont en colère au
bout du bout ils vont voir les élus et
donc ça veut dire qu'ils croient en la
démocratie représentative et or ce qu'on
a essayé de faire sur ce mandat c'est
aussi d'ouvrir justement de faire en
sorte que les profils ressemble
davantage à la diversité de la
population je suis très fière d'avoir
appartenu à un groupe politique dans
lequel on avait la première aide
soignante élus à l'assemblée nationale
où on avait un collègue qui était au rsa
avant d'être élu député fin ça fait
partie des fiertés c'est à dire d'avoir
un groupe qui est beaucoup plus divers
donc moi je partage la critique de d'un
monde qui est trop homogènes
sociologiquement la deuxième critique
elle est sur la potentielle des
connexions c'est à dire le l'entretoit
ça c'est terrible et on voit même
qu'avec twitter et c'est que parfois on
a des polémiques des choses qui sont
très éloignées des préoccupations des
français et c'est un défi de pas se
laisser enfermer aussi là dedans de
sortir le nez de twitter de sortir tout
simplement de discuter avec plein de
gens divers et de se rendre compte que
ce qui nous paraît dans l'hémicycle
incroyablement important devient pas si
important dès qu'on a franchi le seuil
du palais bourbon est ce que vous parlez
souvent avec le président
oui alors souvent je sais pas mais je
lui écris du mail avec des notes plus
détaillé soit c'est un petit message
pour faire monter sur le terrain ça peut
aller du sms jusqu'à une note détaillée
par e-mail ça peut aller une fois une
fois par semaine à une fois par mois
mais dont quoi ce seuil a pas de
périodicité c'est vraiment qu'est ce qui
est plus dur quand on est député
plusieurs c'est ça a été la première
année aussi parce que nous on était
seulement 17 donc je crois qu'on a fait
beaucoup de bruit pour le peu que nous
étions entre guillemets enfin c'était un
17 sur 577 et sa supposée d'un travail
de chien faut être honnête
beaucoup d'organisations et la première
année c'est vrai qu'on a eu une
impression de l'énorme tâche le temps de
comprendre la machine c'est pas évident
au démarrage est de savoir où est-ce
qu'il faut mettre l'effort quelles sont
les priorités c'est ça le plus dur c'est
d'arbitré après on commence à comprendre
où est ce qu'il faut mettre l'effort ou
est-ce que c'est moins indispensable
même si c'est toujours une source de
l'énorme stress bien entendu le stress
des réseaux sociaux notamment qui sont
très très prégnant dans notre vie des
fois un peu trop parce que c'est
l'immédiateté c'est répondre du tac au
tac c'est ses boucles qu'on a aussi sur
notre téléphone nous on a beaucoup de
boucles télégramme donc en permanence on
est sollicité donc c'est la
sollicitation
tout le temps tout le temps le matin dès
le réveil et le soir quand on se couche
à continuer à huy ce que dira
on n'est pas de son parce que sinon
c'est l'enfer il faut pas s'imaginer que
combat il s'arrête à l'élection c'est un
combat permanent et et il faut souvent
se dire quand même que quand on est
député on perd 100 fois pour gagner une
fois à dire que et c'est vrai pour des
députés de la majorité ou de
l'opposition
quand on se lève le matin on sait que ça
va être extrêmement dur et qu'on va
perdre on va perdre des arbitrages des
positions des amendements mais peut-être
une fois dans la journée on a gagné on
se lève pour gagner au moins une fois